EMILY COMPAGNO.
SORRY, MEDIA.
LOOKS LIKE IRAN HATES ITS OWN
GOVERNMENT MORE THAN HE HATES
US.
INSTEAD OF BURNING U.S. FLAGS,
WHAT DID YOU SEE AT SUNDAY'S
PROTESTS OVER ITS GOVERNMENT
SHOOTING DOWN THAT AIRLINER?
A BUNCH OF IRANIANS REFUSING TO
ACT THE WAY OUR MEDIA WISHES
THEY WOULD COME AT DEMONSTRATORS
REFUSED TO WALK ON AMERICAN AND
ISRAELI FLAGS WHILE THEY
ATTACKED IMAGES OF
GENERAL SOLEIMANI.
AS MUCH AS THEY WERE EXPECTED IT
SEEMS THEY LOATHE THE
REVOLUTIONARY GUARD MUCH MORE.
ALSO SHOWED GOVERNMENT FORCES
FIRING LIVE AMMO AT THE
PROTESTERS.
MEDIA OUTRAGE SEEMS AT A LOW
EBB, STILL TOO BUSY COMPLAINING
ABOUT TRUMP TWEETING MEAN THINGS
ABOUT THEM.
YET I RAN, PEOPLE WHO SPEAK OUT
ENDURE ALL LET'S GET THAT OUT
RAGES OVER MEANS, BUT ALSO THE
OSCARS, WHY NO BEST DIRECTOR FOR
LITTLE WOMEN?
FOR GRETA.
I BLAME TRUMP.
ANOTHER MEDIA NARRATIVE
IMPLODES.
WE NOW KNOW HE AUTHORIZED THE
KILLING SEVEN MONTHS AGO.
TALK ABOUT IMPULSIVE, ERRATIC,
UNSTABLE.
HE ONLY WAITED SEVEN MONTHS TO
TAKE THE GUY OUT?
CLEARLY, HE IS A MANIAC, CRAZY
ON BLOOD LUST.
WHERE IS THE 25TH AMENDMENT WHEN
YOU NEED IT?
SO ONCE AGAIN, THE MEDIA LIES TO
YOU ABOUT EVERYTHING.
PART OF THE MADMEN PERSONA THEY
HELPED FABRICATE, NOT TRUE
EITHER.
ONLY IN AMERICA CAN OUR MEDIA
GET EVERYTHING WAS SO WRONG AND
STILL SEE THEMSELVES AS THE GOOD
GUYS.
I GUESS THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN LOOK IN THE MIRROR WITHOUT
THROWING UP.
WELCOME BACK FROM YOUR "TENNIS
CAMP," THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
CALLING IT.
>> Dana: YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE
WHAT I REALLY DID.
>> Greg: CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR
ABOUT IT IN THE BREAK.
DOES THIS FEEL LIKE A NEW
CHAPTER IN IRAN OR IS THAT
WISHFUL THINKING ON MY PART?
>> IT MIGHT BE POSSIBLY BUT IT
WRITES ITSELF OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I BELIEVE THAT EVERYBODY AND
EVERY HUMAN BEING IS BORN WITH A
DESIRE FOR FREEDOM, IT IS
SOMETHING WE ALL HAVE, SO THEN
YOU HAVE A DICTATORIAL
GOVERNMENT THAT IS TRYING TO RAM
DOWN PEOPLE'S THROATS TO KEEP
THEM DOWN, KEEP THEM FROM
OPPORTUNITY, TELL THEM WHAT TO
WEAR, TELL THEM WHAT TO THINK.
THEY WANT THEIR TALENTS AND THEY
WANT THEIR BRAINS BUT THEY DON'T
RESPECT THEIR HEARTS AND SO YOU
SEE THIS IN HONG KONG, VENEZUEL
VENEZUELA, IRAQ, LEBANON, IRAN.
WE WILL GET TO THAT.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE ARAB
SPRINGS, THERE ARE THESE
MOVEMENTS IN AND THEY GET
SNUFFED OUT.
THEN YOU THINK ABOUT VENEZUELA
FOR EXAMPLE, WE KIND OF HELP AT
THEM WE CAN'T DO IT ALL.
SO I DO THINK IT IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME CHANGES BUT THAT WOULD MEAN
IRAN WOULD HAVE TO CHANGE QUITE
FUNDAMENTALLY AND I WOULD BET
THAT THEY ARE BIDING THEIR TIME
RIGHT NOW BUT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THEM IN DECEMBER, KILLED ABOUT
900 OF ITS OWN CITIZENS BECAUSE
THEY WERE PROTESTING AND THIS IS
BEFORE ANY OF THIS HAPPEN.
>> Greg: MIGHT'VE BEEN
DIRECTED BY SOLEIMANI, WHO IS NO
LONGER HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I GET THE FEELING THAT MAYBE
IRAN WASN'T AS OVERJOYED OR IN
LOVE WITH SOLEIMANI AS OUR MEDIA
TOLD US.
>> I BET THE PEOPLE THAT CAME
OUT TO MOURN SOLEIMANI WERE
PEOPLE THAT WERE BACKED BY THE
IRANIAN REGIME.
AND IT IS FUNNY THAT THE MEDIA
HAS TAKEN THE SAME PERSPECTIVE
AS THE IRANIAN REGIME.
THINK ABOUT IT, THEY MOURNED
SOLEIMANI, AND THEN THEY BLAMED
TRUMP FOR SHOOTING DOWN THE
AIRLINE, BOTH THE AMERICAN MEDIA
AND THE IRANIAN REGIME, AND THEN
THEY SAID THAT THE STREET
PROTESTS -- THERE ARE LOTS OF
REASONS FOR PEOPLE TO BE ON THE
STREET, MAY BE SOMEWHERE
SHOPPING, MAYBE JUST OUT GETTING
A BREATH OF FRESH AIR BUT THAT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY
MISUNDERSTANDING THE THREAT OF
PROTESTING IN IRAN.
YOU CAN GET PUT TO DEATH IF YOU
CHANT WHICH THEY WERE DOING.
DOESN'T TAKE ANY BRAVERY TO
CHANT DEATH TO TRUMP, DOWN WITH
AMERICA, IT'S AN EVIL EMPIRE,
EVERYBODY DOES THAT OVER THERE
AND THEY'RE DOING IT BECAUSE
THEY GET PAID TO DO IT.
NOW, WHEN TRUMP GOES IN THERE
AND TAKES OUT A BAD GUY WITHOUT
HAVING TO PAY A BRIBE WITH NO
AMERICAN CASUALTIES, 9 OUT OF 10
AMERICANS GIVE HIM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
ONLY THE MEDIA CREATES A SCANDAL
OVER TRUMP KILLING A TERRORIST.
HOW MANY TERRORISTS DID
BARACK OBAMA TAKE OUT?
AND THE TALIBAN.
HOW MANY GENERALS IN LIBYA
ACROSS THE MIDDLE EAST?
HE DIDN'T HAVE HIS GUYS GO ON
THE SUNDAY SHOWS THE NEXT
WEEKEND TELLING THE MEDIA HERE
IS THE DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE THAT
HE HAD THAT HE WAS PLANNING AN
IMMINENT ATTACK.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THE MEDIA DIDN'T DEMAND
HE DO THAT.
SOLEIMANI'S IN BUSINESS TO KILL
AMERICANS.
HIS JOB FOR THE LAST THREE
DECADES IS TO PLOT ATTACKS
AGAINST AMERICANS AND OUR
ALLIES.
WE DON'T NEED A SPECIFIC PIECE
OF RAW INTELLIGENCE SAYING HE IS
ABOUT TO KILL AN AMERICAN.
IT'S WHAT HE DOES FOR A LIVING.
SO WE KILL HIM FIRST AND THERE
IS NOTHING SCANDALOUS ABOUT THAT
AT ALL.
>> Greg: FEEL FOR YOU TO
RESPOND TO ANYTHING THIS
BRILLIANT MAN JUST SAID.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
START.
THE FACT THAT OBAMA DIDN'T GO
AFTER AND KILL TERRORISTS.
HIS USE OF DRONES TO KILL
TERRORISTS AND PEOPLE SAID WHY
IS HE DOING THIS AND IF WE ARE
GOING TO GO INTO, SHALL BE SEND
TROOPS.
LET ME GO BACK.
>> Jesse: HE WAS NOT HAMMERED
THE WAY THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN HAMMERED.
I DON'T THINK THE REPUBLICANS
WENT CRAZY WHEN BARACK OBAMA.
>> Juan: WHATEVER YOU THINK IS
NOT RIGHT.
YOU ARE CONFLATING TWO VERY
SEPARATE EVENTS.
AFTER SOLEIMANI'S ASSASSINATION
KILLING WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL IT, THERE WERE PEOPLE IN
THE STREETS, I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GUYS SAY MY BUT
NOW THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
STREETS AS MUCH AS AMERICANS
WOULD BE UPSET IF OUR GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN AND AIRLINE, BUT THEY
ARE NOT TO HAVE THE SAME EVENT,
THEY ARE SEPARATE EVENTS AND
THEY HAVE EVERY REASON TO BE
ANGRY AT THEIR GOVERNMENT WHICH
IS NOW ADMITTED THAT THEY LEAVE
A HUGE MISTAKE THAT TOOK 100
PLUS LIVES.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SAYING THEY
HATE THEIR GOVERNMENT MORE THAN
THEY HATE TRUMP.
YOU GO LIVE IN IRAN.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE OTHER PART
OF THIS.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TO BE PUTTING
SCHUMER AND PELOSI IN THIS
PICTURE WITH THIS AT THE
IRANIAN, THIS IS A VIABLE THING
THAT SOMEHOW THEY DON'T GO AFTER
TERRORISTS OR HATE ON PEOPLE,
EVERY DEMOCRAT HAS MADE A CLEAR
STATEMENT THAT HE WAS A BAD GUY.
AND FINALLY, SEVEN MONTHS AGO,
HE GAVE THE AUTHORIZATION THAT
IF YOU HAVE A SHOT, OKAY.
SO THEN TRUMP COMES OUT AND SAYS
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE IF
I HAD INFORMATION ABOUT AN
IMMINENT ATTACK, THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY SAID I NEVER SAW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT, THIS GUY IS
MAKING STUFF UP AND YOU GUYS ARE
JUST RUNNING AROUND, EVERYTHING
HE DOES IS JUST FINE.
>> Greg: WE KNOW YOU WERE ONLY
ALLOWED TO SAY IMMINENT WHEN YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE, ONLY DEMOCRATS CAN USE
THE WORD IMMINENT AND IT HAS TO
DO WITH GLOBAL WARMING.
I HONESTLY THINK WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW IS THE REAL IRAN AND
THE DOOR IS OPENING FOR SOME NEW
DIALOGUE INSTRUCTED BY THE GUY
WHO IS NOW DEAD, SOLEIMANI.
>> Emily: I AGREE AND I WANT
TO SPEAK TO THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE LEFT IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
ON THE PROTEST BECAUSE THE
PROTEST BECAME INCONVENIENT
BECAUSE UP UNTIL THEN, THEY WERE
USED AS A TOOL FOR BOTH OF THOSE
ENTITIES WHEN IT WAS A
ANTI-TRUMP VEHICLE AND THESE ARE
PEOPLE ALLEGEDLY WHO CARED
DEEPLY ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND
FREEDOM AND YET ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THEY ARE MUTE WHEN AS YOU SAID
NOT TWO MONTHS AGO, 1500
CITIZENS WERE MURDERED FOR
PROTESTING.
THEY WERE RISKING THEIR LIVES
BECAUSE THEY ARE SAYING DEATH TO
THE SUPREME LEADER AND
SPECIFICALLY TRUMP IS NOT THE
PROBLEM, SOLEIMANI, THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT IS, THEY ARE
LITERALLY BLOWING OPEN THE SHAM
AND THE BULLYING TO LET THAT
LIGHT IN AND THERE HAVE BEEN
CRICKETS FROM BOTH THE LEFT AND
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
FINAL POINT, THE FOREIGN THREAT
AND THE REGIME THAT IRAN IS,
THAT IS A BIPARTISAN THREAT
BECAUSE WHAT WE DON'T NEED US TO